hey guys if you want to motivate
yourself to crushing in life and support
our channel at the same time check out
anime up Broadcom where you can get your
very own hasta dream big work hard shirt
created by pro manga artist cool
almighty and now for a limited time only
we've also got ultra instinct shaggy
one-shotting Thanos 100% realistic
battle scenario right here
fans of the channel can use the code
uproar 25 to get 25% off link in the
description
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about every I've the Midnight
Sun member and their powers so far I
have done this kind of video for the
magic night captains for the black balls
and now for the eye of the Midnight Sun
I chose to work on this video because a
it was requested and B the Midnight Sun
is shrouded in so much mystery and is
playing a big role in the anime and
manga right now so doing this video just
makes sense plus I am excited to
re-examine the powers of all the members
because there are some really
interesting ones in this group if you
want the black clover videos to keep on
coming make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't
make sure to join the black Bulls of
YouTube by hitting that subscribe button
and ringing that magic YouTube Bell so
you don't miss any new black clover
videos if you want even more black
clover content follow us on Instagram
and Twitter at anime out bra remember to
leave your suggestions for future videos
in the comments and upload suggestions
you like if you haven't guessed by now
there is spoiler magic ahead you've been
warned okay now let's jump into the
madness we're going to be looking at all
of the characters who are or were
members of the eye of The Midnight Sun
however this video will not include
reincarnated elves who are currently
possessing magic Knights since they are
sort of the product of the eye of the
Midnight Sun and more importantly I've
covered their magic in other videos or
will cover it when I get to their magic
Knights squad however there is still a
huge number of characters to look at so
let's get started with some less
important members and then eventually
we'll get to the strongest and most
important members of the group let's
start with Heath grace who believes that
commoners with their small quantities of
magic are nothing more than beasts as a
result he does not hesitate to kill
commoners in his mind he sees them as
undesirable insects rather than as
humans despite how terrible he clearly
is he does have a strong sense of
loyalty after he is captured he does not
hesitate to take his own life
in order to make sure that the magic
Knights can't extract any secret
information about the eye of The
Midnight Sun from him according to the
data book grace scored a three out of
five in physical strength magic amount
magic control and magic sensing a 4 out
of 5 in cleverness and a 5 out of 5 in
punctuality
he possesses ice magic grace mainly
fights using icicles he conducts
executions with the help of his
assistants he creates many icicles in
the air and sends them raining down on
his targets he can also create giant
icicles that shoot out of the ground in
terms of the fence he can create shields
with his ice magic to block enemy
attacks lastly after being captured
Grice uses the spell ice burial to kill
himself and his remaining comrades so
that no one talks heath Grice was our
first real introduction to the eye of
The Midnight Sun and he shows up in the
first volume of the manga The Midnight
Sun has been around since the beginning
of the series and now that we're
approaching 200 chapters all together
they're still around I'm very curious to
see how long the conflict between the
eye of the Midnight Sun will last and
what kind of adventure or threat could
come after them at this point the eye of
The Midnight Sun has pretty much been
around as long as the Black Bulls so
it's difficult for me to even imagine
black clover without them next we have
flues who was one of heath crisis
helpers we don't know a lot about this
hooded figure but we do know that he
possesses water magic he uses the spell
torrential transport to escape from the
black bull's this spell created a stream
of water that carried him to safety and
allowed him to relay what happened to
Patrick
however flu only escaped capture to be
later sacrificed so that the eye of the
Midnight Sun could reincarnate the elves
and then we have Catherine who escaped
from the witch's forest and became a
member of the eye of the Midnight Sun
she is very vain and gets very angry
over negative remarks about her
appearance yet she is very loyal to
Patri and use him as her god her stats
are as follows she scored a 2 out of 5
and physical strength and cleverness a 3
out of 5 in magic sensing a 4 out of 5
and magical Mountain magic control and a
5 out of 5 in desire for you Catherine
actually possesses the same type of
magic as Zora which is Ashe magic
however instead of combining with trap
magic she combines it with curse magic
curse magic spells are not over after
they hit their target they actually
include longer lasting effect
she has the spell ash absorbing
formation which allows her to drain
people's mana and youth victims of the
spell quickly age and deteriorate while
the spell seems to help the witch look
younger herself she also has the spell
joyful destructive ash where she
launches balls of ash towards the enemy
the balls contain curse magic and are
able to deteriorate the target senses if
they land the more ash balls hit the
worse off the target when you know it's
fighting Katherine he ends up
temporarily losing his sight and hearing
his body even goes numb eventually you
know loses access to all five senses but
this improves his ability to detect mana
because of this you know is able to
summon the wind spirit and send the
spell sylphs breath a giant concentrated
ball of wind flying at Katherine
Katherine is able to defend against the
attack by using up the mana she has
collected so far after she uses up her
mana she looks old again and is
desperate for more mana but unlucky for
her Charmy is there to one-shot her
so despite her interesting magic
Katherine was taken out pretty easily
and eventually sacrificed by the eye of
The Midnight Sun next we have George a
calm dude with the big scar on the left
side of his face he respects poetry
because he didn't abandon him when all
others did and he feels like no matter
what he does he could never repay him he
uses wind magic dispel tornado needles
allows George to penetrate people with
multiple needles made out of his wind
magic this move is fast and inflict
serious damage on Austin and Leopold
well luckily for them the magic Knights
that were teleported away come to the
rescue before Austin Leopold can be
finished off like with Katherine the
wizard King uses Marx's memory magic to
get George to spill the beans about
Gelder being a traitor he is later
sacrificed by the add the Midnight Sun
so you can say that Patri didn't really
have his back like George thought now
we're going to get into some members
that we saw in action during the
underwater temple ark toy is an anime
only character meaning he did not appear
in the original manga he possesses
mosquito magic which allows him to fire
several metallic needles around his
opponent these needles give him access
to mosquito like powers the spell
mosquito hum creates a high-pitched
sound
that can distract the target and make it
hard for them to concentrate
although vanessa is still able to move
around pretty well when the spell is
being used against her the spell mana
sucker allows the user to form needles
in the palm of their hands that are
capable of sucking out people's mana for
some reason the mana is stored in the
needles themselves so Vanessa can make
TOI drain his own mana and then she
takes the mana for herself doesn't make
a lot of sense but hey we can't expect a
lot from anime only magic or for that
matter from a filler member of The
Midnight Sun next up we have a member
that is canon's eric the chain magic
wielders eric fights with heavy chains
that are strong enough to break through
rock he is quickly taken out in the
manga by gauche
in the anime zarok lasts longer he looks
stronger than in the manga the chain can
be very long and act on its own his
chains can detect attack magic and then
immediately destroy the mirror goast
summons in the anime he also has a good
defensive move where he creates a
barrier of chains around himself and
successfully blocks Ghosh's mirror
attacks the spell heavy chains makes the
weight at the end of the chains much
bigger and heavier increasing Zarek's
destructive potential gauche even says
he's stupidly strong in the anime
despite how prolong the fight is it
eventually finishes off the same way
with a transform gray distracting him
while the real gauche catches him off
guard and finishes him off with his move
large reflector ray let me know what you
guys think about all the added material
in the anime do you like the fact that
we get some extra anime only material or
would you prefer that they only use
manga material in the anime then there's
Oota and his vine magic after their
victory against Zarek suta traps gauche
and gray with his spell bind vine vines
wrap around them leaving them suspended
in midair unable to move suta's vines
also drain his opponent's magic meaning
they get weaker and weaker the longer
they remain trapped
luckily for gauche and gray they are
able to wake up Charmy and she
effortlessly defeats Zarek by summoning
a giant ram that beats him senseless
next is aw buddy the ball dude with no
pupils he uses spatial magic his spell
different I mentioned sphere
allows him to isolate Yami in another
dimension so he can go help his squad
usually no one should be able to escape
from such a spell but Yami unlocks the
move dark cloak that mentions slash
which allows him to cut through
dimensions no surprise there
this move lets him cut through a birdie
spell and then of course beat him to a
pulp now let's fast forward a bit to the
eye of the midnight sons assault on the
witch's forest
she Don is one of the members present
and probably the biggest pervert in the
group he uses plant magic he is
impressed by faunas magic and by her
beauty as well saying he'd love to have
a shot at her if he ever got the chance
during the operation he hopes to grab
some witches and make them slaves he can
use his plant magic like Goku uses his
Nimbus to fly from one location to
another he also uses his plant magic to
create vines he uses the vines to
capture a number of witches
he hopes to use them later for
entertainment however Austin with some
help from Vanessa has no trouble taking
him out and now we are going to some of
the more important characters in the
group that have been around for a while
first up let's talk about the mad genius
herself Sally she loves experiments
unique forms of magic and biting Austin
she admits that she joined the eye of
The Midnight Sun because they allowed
her to do as many experiments as she
liked
while the magic Knights wouldn't let her
she is now a former member of the group
since Patri decided to sacrifice her
luckily da DiSpirito used his magic to
bring her back to life and ask the
convinced her to help the magic Knights
out in exchange for helping them out
Austin grieves to let Sally investigate
his body as much as she wants and of
course Sally can't say no to that her
stats are as follows she got a 2 out of
5 in physical strength a 3 out of 5 in
magic sensing a 4 out of 5 in magic
amount magic control and cleverness and
a 5 out of 5 and inquisitiveness she
possesses gel magic she usually uses her
magic to summon a big stinky salamander
this salamander can be very useful it is
able to absorb magic captain no zel's
rain of silver attack the salamander
also makes Ghosh's mirror magic
pointless because the beams get
refracted inside the salamander
can manipulate the gel that makes up the
salamander anyway she wants for instance
she uses the gel to grab pasta and she
could also trap things inside the
salamander she can even make salamanders
several storeys tall to match the height
of Henry's Blackpool Mecca so yeah her
magic is pretty good but her real
strength lies in her intellect ever
since she joined forces with them sally
has been a valuable asset to the black
bulls and it was because of her that
they eventually came up with the
strategy to beat the elf possessed
Dorothy I'm glad that I just brought her
back to light because she is always
entertaining to watch now let's talk
about vault o's the sad circus clown of
the group he is extremely loyal to Patri
and is more devastated than Sally when
he figures out that Patri sacrificed
them after he is brought back to life by
it honest he just wants to hear the
truth about what happened from Patri
himself he scored a 2 out of 5 in
physical strength a 4 out of 5 in magic
amount magic control magic sensing and
cleverness in a 5 out of 5 in usefulness
Balto's possess a spatial magic which he
uses earlier on in the series to help
Patri he uses his magic to create
portals that can transport him his
allies or his enemies to desired
locations he was behind the black holes
that teleported most of the magic
Knights away from the capital during the
attack where foo golian lost his arm
when he fought auste he formed a number
of portals around himself that connected
to portals around Austin then he went on
to shoot magic bullets through the
portals however his plan backfired
Aastha used vault OSes own portals to
his advantage
he jumps through a portal to get to
vault o--'s and then punches him in the
face as with Sally ball toss is now
helping out the black bulls to atone for
his sins the black bulls are lucky to
get access to his useful power finra has
spatial magic too but I've never seen
him teleport something as big as the
entire black bull base like Vall toasted
after vol toes we have the guy who
brought him and Sally back to life da
DiSpirito now this is an ex-member of
the purple Orca squad he always seems to
be driven by revenge first he wants
revenge on the clover Kingdom for
banishing him and then later he wants
revenge on Patri for side
you're facing him in the data book his
stats were as follows he scored a three
out of five in physical strength magic
control magic sensing and cleverness a
four out of five in magic amount and of
course a perfect five out of five in
vengeance an artist possesses soul
corpse magic this is a pretty Opie type
of magic that allows him to control
corpses using his mana he can create an
army of regular corpses but what's even
more interesting is that he can also
create much stronger special corpses he
actually numbers these special corpses
so far we've seen number zero to four
number four is called Jimmy and he was
able to shoot magic bullets that
possessed curse magic at the enemy when
someone is hit by one the wound won't
stop bleeding
number three is called David and he uses
muddy water tentacles for battle number
two is called Alfred
not only does Alfred use electricity
magic he can levitate as well and that
makes him difficult to hit number one is
called Carl and he is able to create a
strong magical barrier strong enough to
withstand a powerful fire attack from a
magic night captain Carl can also fire
projectiles at the enemy but this ends
up being his major weakness when the
projectiles are fired the mana barrier
thins in places for a brief moment and
Fuego Leon defeats Carl by taking
advantage of this weakness if a novice
was more careful he probably could have
withstood all of Legault Leon's magic
attacks but as usual he proves to be too
rash for his own good lastly number zero
is called Michael sizzle this corpse is
especially strong because it was made
from the corpses of two former magic
Knight captains because of this it can
use two different elemental types of
magic at the same time namely wind and
Spike magic although number zero has
ghosts Gordon and gray on the ropes
Henry shows up in the nick of time and
is able to defeat the corpse with his
black bull Mecca
later on as if his magic wasn't already
impressive enough and others unlocks a
resurrection spell this spell allows him
to bring himself Sally and Balto's back
to life after Patri tried sacrificing
them now the limits of the spell aren't
clearly outlined so we'll have to wait
and see how he uses it in the future
in the manga it says that his new spell
calls back the souls of the sacrifice
and puts them back into their bodies so
it might only work on sacrifice people
and not on dead people in general I'm
guessing you wouldn't be able to bring
back the wizard king with this spell for
instance nevertheless lastest magic has
a lot of potential but the issue I see
here is that he's now for the time being
on the magic Knights side because he
wants revenge on Patri however I don't
think the magic Knights are gonna take
kindly to him using the corpses of
former magic knight captains to fight
even if he uses them to fight against
the elves perhaps the raddest will act
on his own and create a new special
corpse using the former wizard Kings
body that would surely be his strongest
corpse to date next up we have the third
eye first up we have vetto
the hairy dude that's all about despair
he scored at 3 out of 5 in cleverness a
4 out of 5 in magic Mountain magic
sensing and a 5 out of 5 and physical
strength magic amount and brute force
he possesses beast magic this type of
magic is so rare that julius nova chrono
the magic nerd himself hadn't even heard
of it before his magic allows him to
take on animal attributes that would
assist him in a fight for instance he
can use his mana to form a bear's claw
which drastically increases his attack
power even allowing him to break Yami's
katana he can use the spell rhinoceros
armor to block attacks and the spell
cheat a charge to drastically increase
his speed
this guy is truly impressive after all
it's rare that any one is fast enough to
catch the army off-guard then combine
that with his brood power and you get
quite the deadly foe when his third eye
opens he becomes even more powerful he
uses mythical beasts magic to regrow his
entire right arm after Noel takes it off
mythical beast magic also allows him to
fire strong magic attacks at his
opponents but all of these spells are
written in a language we cannot
understand so we can't give them
specific names interestingly enough when
she sees Vettel with his third eye open
Noel is reminded of the demon that
attacked the city and was eventually
defeated by the first wizard king she
was told that the strongest of these
demonic beings
used forbidden magic to turn himself
into a demon of incredible power and
tried to exterminate humanity so it's
possible that all elves when they
accumulate enough hatred and despair can
become empowered demons however through
teamwork the gang ends up defeating
Vettel and when he is about to
self-destruct Yami shows up and takes
him out with his dark cloak dimensioned
slash attack nevertheless both Vettel
and Al fauna are eventually reincarnated
into artificial bodies created by magic
as Sally
so they're both currently alive and will
probably get to see them fight again
soon enough now let's take a closer look
at fauna fauna the elf takes over the
body of the other fawn Mars's girlfriend
I'll just refer to her as el fauna to
avoid confusion so al fauna is a very
hateful person she is extremely loyal to
Patri and will not hesitate to kill
anyone who hurts them her stats are as
follows she got a 3 out of 5 in
cleverness a 4 out of 5 in physical
strength magic control and magic sensing
any 5 out of 5 in magic amount and
incinerating power al fauna has rare
powers for starters she uses two
different types of elemental magic
namely fire magic and crystal magic this
is usually not possible but al fauna was
able to do it because the diamond
kingdom patched human fanos grimoire
with Mars's grimoire and vice-versa so
that both of them can use each other's
magic and if that wasn't enough el fauna
also possessed the fire spirit
salamander which drastically increases
the users magic amount and power she has
access to healing spells like the fire
spell Phoenix robe which allows the fire
user to heal themselves and/or other
people but she shines when it comes to
offense with crystal magic el fauna can
attack with objects made of crystal her
most powerful attacks though utilized
the fire spirit salamander the attack
salamanders talons sense slashes a fire
magic flying towards the target the
slashes are strong enough to cut and
burn through many trees easily Vanessa
even says that salamander is set to have
the highest attack power of the four
great spirits which is extremely
impressive considering how strong self
Yunos wind spirit
one of the strongest moves we've seen
dalfen I used is salamanders breath
where she uses the fire spirit to launch
a giant ball of fire at her target
unfortunately for Alfe fauna no matter
how strong the spell may be ossicles
still send it flying back at her in the
end
Mars through the power of love is able
to exorcise the elf out of Ana's body
nevertheless elf fauna and salamander
were powerful opponents as I mentioned
before the elf fauna does get
reincarnated into an artificial body but
she no longer has salamander who is now
with fuego leone honestly I could not be
happier that forego Leone ended up
inheriting the spear with the highest
attack power but goliad's future fights
are definitely gonna be lit then we have
Raya in my view the strongest member of
the third eye unlike the other two he
doesn't die before getting fully
reincarnated despite facing off against
meteo Leona he is known as Riya two
disloyal but he seems pretty loyal to
the elves so far although this might
foreshadow some future complications
after all he was momentarily touched by
Austin's words when tossed aside he'll
create a country where everyone can live
in acceptance and laugh with one another
so maybe he will eventually come around
but for the time being
riot disloyal has ironically been
extremely loyal to the eye of the
Midnight Sun his statistics are as
follows he scored a 4 out of 5 in
physical strength magic sensing and
cleverness and a 5 out of 5 in magic
amount magic control and disruptive
power he possesses imitation magic when
he touches someone's grimoire he can
copy their spells but it doesn't work
properly with hasta Santa magic notably
the copied attack is not necessarily
weaker than the original in fact the
stolen magic power strength is converted
to his own tremendous magic power so he
usually far surpasses the power of the
original so far we have seen riah used
light magic dark magic spatial magic
permeation magic water magic and even
fire spirit magic since he's still alive
he can keep adding more types to his
already Opie collection furthermore
after being fully reincarnated he can
now use more than one elemental type of
magic at the same time making him even
or LP he could use permeation magic in
combination with light magic for
instance which would make him near
invincible I could go on about the
insane speeds he can reach using light
magic in combination with spatial magic
or the tremendous amount of magic power
he possesses but I think you get the
point
after his full reincarnation he is a
formidable opponent and partly due to
his easygoing attitude he remains my
favorite member of the third eye now we
have reached the elf that has been
leading the eye of the Midnight Sun all
this time
Patri Patri shares William bonds it's
his body and surprise surprise he wants
vengeance he wants revenge on all humans
so William's last name definitely
foreshadowed this but it wasn't as
straightforward as might be expected
since it is not William who wants
vengeance but an elf that secretly
shares his body
Patri statistics are as follows he
scored a four out of five in physical
strength magic sensing and cleverness
and a five out of five in magic amount
magic control and leadership he
possesses a rare four-leaf clover
grimoire that contains light magic
spells
not only does he have opiate acts like
ray of divine punishment and arrows of
judgment light magic is also said to be
the fastest type of magic in addition to
that he has access to healing magic and
reincarnation magic but she may not be
the strongest character in the show but
he was able to come up with a way to
defeat the wizard King himself showing
that he can think quick and devise
effective plans even in the heat of
battle and there's only one more
character after Patri that we'll be
talking about in this video and he is
the person that pops you pretended to be
at the beginning of the series of course
I'm referring to Blake the leader of the
elves who has been brought back to life
thanks to Patri who has attained the
required magic stones and subsequently
resurrected all the elves Luke doesn't
seem to be quite himself yet and he
never voluntarily joined the odd The
Midnight Sun per se but we can't not
include him in this video because of how
important he is and how clearly tied up
with the actions of the group he is lick
possess his sword magic austin's
grimoire and Sora's used to belong to
him Licht is extremely powerful and is
able to take out both austin you know at
their strongest without much trouble
since he's been resurrected he prefers
to fight with the diamond while her
sword witch
uses exceptionally well he is able to
absorb the strongest magical attacks and
send them flying back at the enemy he is
extremely quick to the point where
Austin's eyes cannot even keep up with
his speed and the quarry Casta like ski
and mana cannot even be sensed he is
able to use top-level forbidden spells
like the one that summoned the ancient
demon it is clear that we have yet to
see what he is truly capable of but it
is already obvious that he is the
strongest opponent our main characters
have had to face so far and that is it
for today's video guys thanks so much
for watching if you are really curious
about all of the elves that got
reincarnated into magic night bodies
dead let me know and I might make a
special video about all the elves and
their enhanced powers make sure to smash
that like one if you joined the video
and join the black poles of YouTube by
hitting that subscribe button and
ringing that magic YouTube Bell if you
are burning up to see a specific video
let me know what it is in the comments
if you're starving for more black clover
you can always get even more content on
our instagram and twitter at anime
uproar and if you're like me and you
want to use anime to help motivate
yourself to crush in life you should
check out our austin dream big work hard
t-shirt at anime out Broadcom i will put
a link in the description and fans can
get 25% off by using the code uproar 25
thank you again for all of your support
it means a lot to me and until next time
see us space cowboy
[Music]
you